Well, the answer is this one. This is the path that the light is taking in the end prime frame.
It's moving at a slight diagonal that means the total d' this whole distance up and back down is 2ct'.
Okay, so this side is ct', this side is h, and this side well its vt'.
It's the speed of the train, v times the time a lot that's how far the train has advanced.
So, actually, I have this wonderful right triangle, base, height of h and hypotenuse is ct'.
I'm going to do the Pythagorean theorem, this squared plus that squared must equal this squared,
and when I do that, I get v²t'² + h² equals--well, this side squared
and I'm writing the t' in red just so we can keep focus on them.
Now, actually, what I want to do is I want to solve for t'
so, I'm going to move this term over to this side and what I've done here is I've factored out the t'²
and then I'm going to divide both sides by this c²-v²  so now, I have this.
My next step is a bit of a trick so what I'm going to do is I'm going to divide
both the numerator and the denominator on the left hand side by c²
and since I'm doing each both the numerator and denominator that's totally fine
and what I get when I do that is this
and now, may be you can start to see why I decided to divide by c².
I did that because when we look at these two equations.
These are both d so I can set them equal to each other, 2h = 2ct.
The 2 is canceled and t is equal to h/c.
Remember this is the unprimed t so what I can do is replace this h/c with t.
Now, what I have is a relationship between the time measured on, well unfortunately I erased red,
but measured on red's clock and the time t measured on green's clock.
Let's just take the square root of both sides, and I find that the time measured on t',
the red clock is equal to the time measured on this guy's clock
with this mathematical expression modifying it.
I would have no reason to believe that two identical clocks should ever run at different rates,
but what I found here is that it is not only that the clocks are running at different rates
that time itself can't be universally specified.
My time is not the same as your time if we're moving relative to each other.
This is amazing. Let's look at this equation in a little more detail.